So last week Brad noticed that Congress was kind of acting weird
and asked me to take a look at him
and once I saw him it was really clear that he was having trouble breathing
and that he needed to go to the emergency clinic right away.
And I don't want to brag, but I'm
very calm and collected in a time of crisis
*screaming*
He's gonna die!
I'm so sorry buddy!
Don't die!
Where is the closest vet clinic?
Why didn't i look this up a month ago?
What's wrong with me?
so once we got there Congress was put into an oxygen incubator
and had x-rays done
which revealed that not only does he have fluid in his lungs,
but he has an enlarged heart
he had an "insane amount" of gas in his stomach and intestines
and he has a leg that doesn't even have a socket to connect to his hips.
So he's just lived his entire lie with a leg floating in his body.
And I felt so horrible, you know
because Congress is like a "pure-bred cat."
Humans did this to him
we literally did this to him, he should not exist
but luckily the doctor came in and reassured me that congress wasn't in any pain
but he also said:
Unfortunately this just happens with Persian breeds.
Due to his heart enlargement he's going to have to take
3 medications every day for the rest of his life
and sometimes the meds work,
and sometimes they don't.
But we don't know how long he's going to live
and that hit me, you know, in a weird way
that sentence:
"We don't know how long he's going to live."
Because on one hand, I mean it does, I mean it's terrifying
but it also makes me wanna spend every day cuddling Congress
because I don't know how long I'll have him.
But on the other hand:
"We don't know how long he's going to live"
Can't this be said of everyone?
I mean, we have no idea how long any of us are going to live.
But should I be treating everyone in my life like a doctor told me:
"We don't know how long he's going to live."
I mean, I'm the kind of person who reminds myself of death all the time.
Especially in the happier moments of my life.
I could be like taking shots with my friends
and I'll just randomly cheers
Cheers!  Cheers!  (Unison)
Everyone!
We're all gonna die!
But no matter how real death is
and like its inevitability a guarantee,
I feel like life is so long
that you just
forget.
It convinces you that nothing bad is ever going to happen to you.
So when something bad eventually does happen to you,
I still feel so thrown.
and its such a weird balance you have to have
with accepting your mortality
because it's like, you also can't live every day like it's  gonna be your last.
That would lead to horrible decisions.
We're all gonna die...
Congress is okay right now.
He has a follow up appointment this week to see how the meds are working out.
But he seems as happy and as hungry as ever.
But I don't know man--
this whole experience made me think like
of course, like I wanna take more moments out of my days
to really enjoy and be in the moment
when I'm in the company of like
not only my cats of course
but also like my family and friends
because I know this isn't forever
but I'm not necessarily grateful
for the time I get to spend with them
and I'd like to be more mindful of that.
But what about you?
Have you had any brushes with death recently?
Any existential crises, brought on by the inevitability of our demise?
and when you do think about these, these horrible things
do you feel more at peace?
or do you have like the opposite reaction?
I'm Anna Akana
Stay awesome Gotham.